elle salue les dix les dix bienvenue sur
mon vidéos blogs et les beauty et salue
bienvenue sur mon vidéoblog le ellen
beauty beauté masque club chaque semaine
et tous les jours même je vous donnerai
fin en fonction du planning
je vous donnerai des petits conseils des
petites astuces pour savoir comment
c'est qu'on a du glamour comme moi le
jugement
non alors aujourd'hui une mission
spéciale pour savoir comment c'est qu'on
a de l'élégance
quand on est à table alors ça peut être
par exemple pour un dette
ça peut être par exemple pour un repas
d'affaires avec des chinois
ça peut être par exemple quand c'est
qu'on va dîner chez des parents à
pierrick alors première chose premiers
conseils astuces consomme déjà le
bouquin de nadine de rothschild on jette
à la poubelle s'il vous plaît voilà
parce que on est plus en 1982 nadine à
l'eau c'est qu' à l'appareil
alors ce soir vous êtes invités et oui
disons chez un collègue qui a invité des
gens pour célébrer une petite fête à
l'occasion des derniers événements qui
sa pendaison
qui
la marmite bas son fils puis une date de
naissance qui la fin la pac voilà alors
les filles 1ère chose
firstep il faut envoyer du pâté envoyait
du pâté ça veut dire mettre des beaux
vêtements mais pas que des beaux
vêtements
ça c'est mon astuce conso il faut
accessoirisé parce que halo c'est qu' on
n'est pas des bonnes soeurs les sujets
mais les ballons des accessoires parce
que si tu reviens je te ferai dire
qu'elles ont par exemple la toque
lacroix la ceinture des glisses les
baskets et que le réseau des baskets
non ça c'est des sandalettes d'église
mais le reste toi tu considère ça comme
des accessoires
parce que moi ça me change son truc
pierrick deuxième chose ce concept il
faut jamais arrivé les mains vides en
une fête les filles bennett
d'abord ça fait radin et ensuite ma
petite astuce à moi c'est que si vous
aimez ou pas qu'est ce qu'on vous
propose
vous avez toujours que ce que vous avez
ramené voilà ensuite deuxième petit
conseil qui va vous êtes bien utile
aussi après moi j'apporte toujours
quelque chose que c'est en rapport avec
la personne âgée qui nous invite un qui
nous invite mais c'est la personne qui
nous a oui la belle a personne qui sait
qu'ils nous invitent un petit cadeau
personnalisé ça fait toujours pas de mal
et puis ça
toujours plaisir aussi par exemple tiens
on sait qu'il a une voiture et ben va
rapporter un magazine automobile tient
madame et gourmande et ben tiens on va
rapporter une petite boîte d'escargots
tient ainsi qu'il a perdu sa femme dans
un accident grave d'un casque ne tienne
moi j'apporte une collègue ou même à une
amie quelque chose qui vivent qui fait
plaisir
alors troisième chose seconde step la
conversation c'est important les filles
il suffit pas d'être tendance branché
cool cool
il faut aussi avoir un peu de grande
intelligence quand même hein donc moins
un petit conseil perso c'est de ne pas
hésiter à regarder un peu tous des
magazines people tout ça avant d'aller
chez les gens comme ça ça fait des
petits sujets a lancé à la cantonade
tiens je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais apparemment rika zaraï n'est pas
décidé voilà donc la selle un souci de
la conversation et là il y en a pour
toute une soirée de conversion injuste
grâce à une petite info people
tiens vous avez remarqué apparemment
afrique hasard elle n'est toujours pas
décédée
la dernière petite astuce pour briller
devant les collègues
et ben moi ce que je vous trouvez à vous
conseiller c'est que si vous avez un
petit alain tâche est quelque part eh
ben il faut le montrer ça fait plaisir
et ça met des valeurs en toi alors moi
j'ai mon homme il a une limitation
presque parfaite d'un chanteur que tout
ne connaît bien
et oui c'est jean pierre goldman alors
attention pierrick savate être à toi
maintenant qu'eric vraiment pas toi